-Guys, we have exactly
nine shows left before
we go on Christmas break,
which means it is time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for
"12 Days of Christmas Sweaters."
Come on.
-♪ 12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ 9 days left ♪
-That is right.
Every show between
now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a noice Christmas sweater
from the
"Countdown to
Christmas Cabinet."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, since there are
nine shows left,
let's open door number 9.
[ Drumroll ]
You ready, bud?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, here we go.
Oh, let's take a look at it.
Yeah.
♪♪
Let's take a peek at it.
Oh, my gosh.
Wow.
That is --
You could tell by the reaction.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You could tell by
the reaction in the audience
that everyone
wants to wear this.
It is gorgeous.
"Noel," it says on there.
So, let's see who is going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look at
your seat number, okay?
And if I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get
a drumroll, please?
-Yep.
[ Drumroll ]
-Who wants a sweater?!
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Come on down!
Nice to see you, buddy.
Right there, pal.
Have a spot over there.
Hello. What is your name?
And where are you from?
-My name is Donovan,
and I'm from London.
-Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Donovan from London.
Well, Donovan, it does get cold
in London, doesn't it?
-Very cold now, yeah.
-Yeah.
-And do you have anything
like this in your wardrobe?
-No way, man.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, no way --
-This is the first time.
-Yeah. It's one of a kind.
Do you want to try it on?
Yeah, over the sweatshirt, yeah.
-Yeah, I'll put it on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There's no real front or back.
Don't worry about that.
Yeah, I don't even know if there
are holes in it, to be honest.
I don't know if you can
put your head through,
but this -- Look at this.
Oh, no, Don, I can already tell.
I could already tell.
Oh, my goodness!
This is looking good.
Look at that!
Come on, now.
Don, spin around.
Yeah, let me see it!
Let me see it.
Oh!
[ Laughs ]
That's what I'm talking about.
Yo! Congratulations!
It looks great on you.
Let's give our winner
a round of applause.
Stick around.
We'll be back with
"Show Me Something Good"
talent show.
Come on back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪